explain to me what happened in this case
because obviously it all fell apart
after you going through the arduous task
of going through a police investigation
and then being passed on to the CPS why
did this not lead to cause fear I think
there's a couple of different reasons
the first one is that the toxicology
report is quite flawed so this all comes
down to consent right now there is no
debate on whether or not sex happened my
attacker said in his statement that it
happened and in addition the police
found used condoms on the scene the
problem is that I don't even remember
meeting this man until I woke up next to
him naked on a hotel bed so for me I
need to be able to prove that I was
incapable of giving consent for sex and
there's a couple of reasons that the
police had a flawed investigation the
first one being that they gave the wrong
timeline to the toxicology lab and this
is something that I've been flagging
with both the police and the CPS since I
finally got a copy of that toxicology
report about six months after my final
appeal to the CPS in that report it
shows that they say my last memory was
at 7 p.m. but it was actually at 4:00
p.m. which is a pretty big difference
when you're trying to figure out blood
alcohol levels as well as the potential
for being dosed with the drug and the
only thing is that it shows is that my
attacker had not a single drop of
alcohol in his system and was found in
possession of both viagra and LSD you
say the police investigation is full we
do just have to give them Oh solace in
the police's response to that the Met
Police say that it carried out a
thorough investigation following these
allegations and will always provide
support to anyone who reports a serious
sexual offense the Crown Prosecution
Service said having looked carefully at
all the available evidence a specialist
prosecutor decided there was
insufficient evidence for a realistic
prospect of conviction in this case now
you feel so strongly about this I'm very
impressed at how together you are about
in terms of what must have been an awful
experience what must have been an
arduous process but you're taking
matters into your own hands hands now
and you're wanting to bring a private
prosecution which is costly so you are
asking people to help funds about what
do you think that you will get a better
result through private prosecution
absolutely so it's two and a half years
later and I'm a lot stronger than I was
I wouldn't be sitting here other
it's taken me a long time to be healed
enough to be able to talk about this in
public as I mentioned there's some deep
problems with with the police
investigation itself but they're fixable
basically all we need to do is some new
math and then all of a sudden it's a
very much more straightforward case the
police saying that they provide support
to anyone is sadly not what my
experience was maybe if I'd been
provided with some support it would have
gone a lot more easily but no matter how
much I asked for support they didn't
provide it and indeed they didn't even
refer my case to victim to support until
December so I was raped in May and I got
a call from Victim Support in December
of that year saying the police had just
referred my case